London is home to some of the most
expensive real estate in the world so
pricey in fact that thousands of
Londoners priced out of the market are
swapping traditional brick and mortar
homes for ones bobbing on the waters of
the city's historic canals but as
Jonathan Vigliotti reports these
floating housing alternatives have given
rise to some unforeseen problems
London's meandering canals look like an
oasis on a sunny spring afternoon but
increasingly
they're a last resort for many who say
the city has left them nowhere else to
go I just thought the only way that I'm
ever going to be able to earn any
property is by buying a boat because the
concept of buying a flat for a million
pounds is just way out of my reach you
know especially when you're earning
teachers wages auntie winter is among
hundreds of people who unable to make
ends meet in the capital gave up life in
an apartment to live on a narrow boat
the quirky vessels can be just five feet
wide and 20 feet long with enough space
for up to two beds but starting at
around $25,000 there is steel compared
to property prices and word has caught
on in the past five years the number of
boats on the canals has jumped 64% more
than 10,000 people live on the water a
combination of economics and
desirability driving those numbers in
fact the canals are so popular
increasingly there's not enough room so
we're ahmed with the canal and river
trust says the capital's 100 miles of
waterways are packed what we're finding
is that there's a little bit of conflict
where people want to have more space to
stop but obviously the numbers of boats
that are passing through I mean those
there are two kinds of boat people those
who have their own fixed mooring or
parking space and those who only have
much cheaper cruising licences which
means they have to move their boat every
two weeks we were hoping to stop just
before Regents Park but there wasn't the
mooring so we had to go through London
Zoo
David Cotter and Juliet McCrimmon are
new converts to narrow boat life and
live on there's part-time
I think the main logistical thing with
the boat that I've learned is and it's a
good lesson for life really is you can't
have a deadline you can't have to be
somewhere at 2:00 p.m.
life on a narrow boat is nothing new
bargees as they're known have lived on
UK canals for centuries it used to be a
rather primitive lifestyle but times
have changed this is I suppose the
living living area
I've got dishwasher but and that really
sucks because I love
Yuval washing machine that's Linda
O'Hare has lived on her boat and worked
in the city for 18 years you look at the
canal and it's packed with those it's
not a single space what was it like 810
years ago oh there was hardly anything
18 years ago there was there were boats
around but you could travel for a couple
of hours and you wouldn't see another
boat O'Hare owns her own mooring so
doesn't mind the company of new boaters
people like Andy winter who've been
priced off the land but have found a way
of life on the water you can own
somewhere that you can call your home
that's perfectly reasonable to live in
without having to find millions and
millions of pounds of going to debt for
the rest of your life for CBS this
morning Saturday Jonathan Vigliotti
London it looks really pretty I'm ready
to do it in New York but no dishwasher
is a problem a barge on the Hudson oh
boy no dishwasher a deal-breaker sorry